the Joe Rogan experience and I tell
people all the time like you know just
because you know we get so caught up
like right now is like an emotional time
for America right it's getting ready to
I call it the draining time you know
from now until you know November you
know until the election time it's gonna
be draining right and everybody's
getting so emotional and fired up and
yeah and it's like you know like it's
gonna be whatever but the cool part is
is that this country like from all of us
in the military from all our first
responders our police officers you know
we're the only country on the face of
planet that doesn't swear allegiance to
a person we swear allegiance to a
document to a piece of paper and that's
what that's what allows us to be us
that's what allows us to not have one
person come in and be able to change up
this idea that we have of democracy of
freedom and and that's that's that's
something that's just it's incredible
that's what keeps our country the way it
is right like there's not you know the
people will always be in charge here and
you know what most of America most
ninety-nine percent of America is
incredible it's incredible and you know
what they're gonna they're stopping and
they're helping people and it's just
allowed ones that make us look you know
make it look like it's all chaotic well
people love to point out the horrible
aspects and they're loved to ignore the
good aspects they love to dwell on the
bad parts and I think ultimately that's
going to prove to be good for everybody
because those people that are
highlighting all these bad things then
everybody else has to think about it and
we'll slowly but surely evolve and come
to an understanding and and and and make
the world a better place it's a way
better place now than it was a hundred
years ago or two hundred years ago and I
think this is a I mean Steven Pinker
talks about this all the time in his
books but and it's criticized for it
because a lot of people don't like the
idea that things are getting better they
want to dwell on the negative aspects
and they want to they want to magnify
those and make it the most important
focal point I think the most important
focal point if we won't have a good
world is concentrate on the good aspects
and and how amazing it really is that we
have this incredible ability to express
ourselves this incredible ability to
prosper to move and I mean you know
people don't get the the same share or
the same stake in life a lot of people
get a terrible opening hand of cards
yeah but you can improve and this is one
of the rare places in the world where
you can if you're if you're so inclined
if you have the discipline if you could
figure it out emotionally if you could
figure it out in terms of like what you
want to do in your life you can you can
live a healthy a healthy and successful
life in this country it's possible it's
a hundred percent 100% like nobody's
holding you down right like you have the
choice to be able to do that you have
the choice to go out every opportunities
here like there's no other country that
has more opportunities in the United
States of America especially for me for
anybody and and I agree with you I think
that this society has gotten into this
to this place of where we're trying to
out victimize each other like who can be
the bigger victim who's had it harder
yeah and and you know it's it's the the
thing that I also believe is that with
technology and all this is the empathy
like like suffering has became normal
for people right like it's became
entertainment like look at reality TV
like people's messed up lives that's
entertainment for people now right video
games of you know and I talk about this
all time about war right we came back
and it was we like the war has now been
romanticized it's been romanticized that
it's this cool image of like I hear
people say yeah I just want to go kick
in doors and shoot people in the face
and it's like wow you you've probably
never done it then and it's like we've
got our kids playing video games of the
stuff that keeps me awake at night and
it's like you know at what point do we
start humanizing these things when you
see one of those crazy video games first
person shooters involved in war does
that bring back memories I mean does it
does it or is it does it irritate you it
you know it like you know I I under I
think that what's not put out there is
is you know I hear kids talking about
hey you know did you use this or did you
use this or did you know I you hear
people say well did you kill somebody
right it's like like kids and I don't
think that that's you know I like to me
that bothers me
because it's not there's nothing cool
about taking another human's life and
and when you're playing video games and
it's like I got you know this many kills
like these kids are just watching this
screen over and over and the more you
know the more graphic it gets the like
the less desensitized that we have to
another human being suffering Brian the
more these on stitch yeah desensitize
right like the more desensitized and
then you start you know the the more the
movies go and the more I mean you know I
think I think it like we've just like
we've pushed ourselves away from you
know from being empathetic to hey dudes
are real people these are real people's
lives like what if they you know we've
stopped looked in it looking at people
and saying you know this is someone's
child yeah this is someone's mother
right this is someone's son I okay we've
we've gotten away from that and like
like the the you know the old art that I
was always told to live by to treat
someone as you'd want to be treated
yourself and if you were in those shoes
and every time I pass somebody every
time I see somebody suffering I always
look at that and be like well what would
I want somebody to do if they see my
daughter suffering or my son suffering
right I mean look at all these Tom's ask
these people holding their video cameras
up in their video and somebody like
getting just beat and it's like wow how
do you do that not help how does that
not just suck everything out of you to
not want to do something yeah there's a
thing called diffusion of responsibility
that happens people in crowds
unfortunately and it's also the same
thing that I think when you're filming
something that's happening in real life
is the same thing that you've seen in
these video games and on television
shows mean we we have never had more
violence in film form and in video game
form ever ever but yet we've never had
less violence violence like how many
people who play these games that have
seen people get shot over and over and
over and over again I've never seen a
body never seen anybody get severely
wounded or shot and so to them getting
shot and shooting people is always it's
almost like empty it's like bang bang
bang there's the
guy comes out of the bushes bang bang
bang you shoot them here comes this guy
penny bang you shoot him and it doesn't
feel like anything and then you shut it
off and you have a sandwich then you
turn it on again you do it again yeah so
you're you're experiencing this thing
that's empty it's it's like you're
pretending to drink water but there's
nothing in the glass you just keep doing
it over and over again and then you get
some real water and you're like oh this
is this is different yeah this is there
that's not even a good night that's a
terrible analogy but the analogy of
numbing that people are numb to this
fake violence and have no experience
with the real stuff so they think of the
real stuff the same way they think of
the fake stuff they do and and then you
know and sometimes when they see it they
still or not they still can't act right
like they still don't it's kind of like
it's kinda like imagine the way I look
at it is you know you look at all these
simulators like flight simulators like I
mean there's all this virtual reality
right of that people are using this for
actually training and so like you don't
think that it's the same way when you're
doing this and then you got games that
come out like Grand Theft Auto right
like where you're just running around
and you're shooting hookers running like
yeah like how does that how is that how
is anything positive come from that
right right how is it anything possible
yeah it's um we're a weird culture
[Applause]